hallo mein name ist luca und der name
von ihr ihr kollege eigentlich männlich
oder weiblich
cooliris name ist okay und wir haben uns
gedacht dass wir heute mal wieder eine
runde akinator spielen allerdings war
yao polizisten allerdings will ich heute
nicht nicht suchen oder irgendwie anders
sondern wir wollen ökologie suchen ich
hatte auf twitter und morgen schon die
frage ob ich heute auf dem alten
intendis oder mit ökologie akinator ich
sollte aufhören für alles irgendwie
namen zu erfinden weil ihr direkt so
über das rein steigert ich habe auch
letztens auf instagram einfach dieses
bild hier gefunden wo einfach mein
komplettes leben in bezug auf youtube in
einem bild zusammen gefasst wurde
ukulele und balu aber wir wollen direkt
anfangen unterstützt uns in akinator und
wo ich bin ich bin unter den letzten
zehn spielen auf diese frage
bitte denken sie an der real oder
fiktive figur ich werde versuchen sie zu
erraten mein alltag wie alt ist okay ich
schreib mal eins weil sie ja dieses jahr
ist geboren wurde wurde da eine figur
durch youtube berühmt ja hier kleine
figuren micro mit nein die ist eine
figur männlich wir müssen jetzt mal ein
geschlecht für ukulele festlegen die
machen eine umfrage er schreibt in die
kommentare männlich wenn ihr denkt du
kollege soll männlich sein und schreibt
weiblich wenn ihr denkt o'leary ist
weiblich sondern gucke ich nicht mal
durch und wovon mehr kommentare drin
sind dass uns das geschlecht von nicolae
dies tut mir leid dass es so eine
unpersönliche methode ist aber ich hoffe
dass es in die luft weg ich gebe einfach
mal weiß ich nicht ein ist deine figur
aufhäuser hat eine figur tattoos nein
hat deine figur
ueli wissen hast das ist ja es ist im
kollegium sie wurde schon 2007 178 mal
gespielt wir machen jetzt mal einen
anderen text zwar versuche ich jetzt bei
lud zu finden also bald dieser hund muss
intern doch wo ich in nintendogs den mir
gekauft wir fangen an wurde deine figur
des youtube berühmt ja spieler eine
figur mein kräften ein praktikum
männerkleidung nein ist das nicht
rigoros holz nein hatte blondes haar
nein lebt eine figur in deutschland ich
weiß nicht seine figur ein tier ja noch
zwei bahnen ein
meine figur kann nicht fliegen ist eine
figur ein hund ja ich sie kommt da eine
figur aus deutschland wahrscheinlich ist
deine figur weiblichen balu ist männlich
glaube ich ja ich habe mich über jung
genommen da hab ich in diesen männlichen
schwarzen einfach hier so bestätigen ist
eine figur älter als sein großvater nein
mach deine figur röstaromen röstaromen
sehen aus wie kakao bohnen sind es
einfach geröstete kakaobohnen ich kenne
mich mit so was überhaupt nicht aus
bitte urteil tatsächlich hat deine figur
wirklich existierten 1 ist eine deutsche
oder österreicher ich weiß nicht seine
figur graue wahrscheinlich nicht stand
eine figur aus einem spiel ja nicht die
jugendfreie wieso ist vermutlich weil
war lewis anscheinend nicht jugendfrei
ich versuche jetzt als letzte person
diese flasche wasser versuchen und nein
es ist kein placement für witte ich mag
die das wasser ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
aber es gab nichts anderes wurde deine
figur durch youtube bekannten ein hatte
seine figuren handy nein es sind die
kommentieren
natürlich wie die beiden eine figur
armen ein dass das holz nein das dann
viel kleiner als ein meter hat eine
figur etwas mit nahrung zu tun ja kalt
heutig und gleich nein ist eine figur
war als ok ist deine figur hässlich
jürgen winter hält eigentlich schon lebt
oder lebte deine figur mönchengladbach
nein kann man seine figur essen nein hat
eine figur einen runden eine figur aus
einer flasche ja kommt eine figur aus
russland nein es sind figuren junger
mann ist eine figur süßen nein es hat
gerade blumen benannt ist eine wippe
blume also wenn ich titel blume eingebe
kommt eigentlich nichts sinnvolles also
würde ich sagen nein ich weiß wenn du
denkst aber ich denke das ist nicht
jugendfrei ist alles klar klar ja alles
klar
na klar als klar ist ja alles klar als
lara alles klar klar klar das heutige
ergebnis von akinator ist einmal
ökologie direkt gefunden und zweimal
verkackt alles klar alles klar
ja ja klar wenn euch das video gefallen
dafür bin ich mich über eine bewertung
freund schreibt mir die kommentare ob
männlich oder weiblich ist dann werde
ich das auch von euren kommentaren aus
auf jeden fall mal versuchen dann zu
luca ukulele